oops welcome to this video we got a
Carol com hmm ok so let's play them the
pawn off leading to UM we open position
often with an isolated Queen porn young
94s the line that I played myself a
couple of times and here this is a
gambit when I can't take the pawn it is
very risky but of course I have
forgotten the details black can take
it's not a bad move but it's a it's as
mentioned very risky ah how on earth is
plates us I think this is right f4e five
and probably a form
at least this looks yeah looks like it
to make some sense
no idea no idea Bishop g4 maybe at least
his thinking this can mean two things
I'm already I already deviated from the
from the known alliance or he forgot the
the line and maybe doesn't know more
than than me yeah Bishop g4 but maybe I
can just take a five then it's possible
okay
but I can take you five no you should
take C for opt for us is quite bad I
mean quite bad this Wow particular
it takes I mean if it takes e4 I take g7
and detect the rope here
maybe
it's really curious ah okay okay if I
take I understand if i take it's got
Bishop h6 but if i take here chance to
check young i'm just a piece up now and
I mean Bishop h6 you can check whatever
he wants its it is just the check yeah
so take here check just keep it simple
I'm a piece up
check
okay so
you may be here just protect this and
ask the look what it is doing check
95
hmm yeah doesn't really matter
you check
black resigns yeah it's just a piece for
for a while ya think really the Sun yeah
therefore I think it i think it's it's
Bishop g4 but don't know I think this is
a well-known line with Bishop g4 but
this this is just not working I mean F
take C fibers plus two if you believe
the comp long castles and just take it
check yeah yes just a piece he drag this
on for a while for no particular reason
but yeah okay the essence is if you play
such an super sharp line you should know
your stuff yeah in fact the the line
that the computer gives here and that
calculated the line is not from an
opening book I think this is in fact the
way it is played Bishop takes GF and
rook c8 I think I saw this i'm done
here's something something like this
it's the way this is played with the
with okay chances for black but they're
ok I don't know it in detail something
like that alright thanks for watching